ASSEMBLY MEMBER BAUER K. HAND
NOTICES THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS REPAIR
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY
ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BROUGH BURKE. CALDERON
CARRILLO. CERVANTES CHAU. CHEN
DAVID CHIU. CHOI KANSEN CHU.
COOLEY COOPER. CUNNINGHAM DALY.
DALY DEEP EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA
RAMOS RAMOS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE. TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
MEMBERS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER. AND IN THE
GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND FOR THE
PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE
OFFERED BY OUR ASSEMBLY
CHAPLAIN THE REVEREND PATTY
OSHA PRODUCTION. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN A MOMENT OF REFLECTION. FOR
EIGHT YEARS WE ENJOYED WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR PAST BISHOP
SOTO CAUCHY NOGUCHI. EVEN NOW
WE ADMIRE HIS ABILITY TO
HONESTLY RESPOND TO EVEN THE
MOST DIFFICULT RESPONSIBILITIES
OF HIS OFFICE. I REMEMBER ONCE
HE CONTEMPLATED THE FUTURE OF
AN UNHAPPY MINISTER WHO WAS
ASKED TO LEAVE THREE
CONSECUTIVE TEMPLES. WHEN THEY
MET BISHOP AGREE TOLD HIM.
LETTING YOU GO IS THE MOST
COMPASSIONATE THING I CAN DO.
THE MINISTER WAS CONFUSED AND
UPSET. BISHOP AGREE CONTINUE I
DON'T WANT YOU TO WASTE YOUR
ONE AND ONLY PRECIOUS LIFE
TRYING TO DO SOMETHING YOU
CANNOT DO. BISHOP THEN ASKED
HIM. ISN'T IT TRUE THAT YOU ARE
RARE LEE HAPPY IN ALMOST ALWAYS
COMPLAINING. THE MINISTER COULD
SAY NOT THEM. BISHOP AGREE
ENDED ENCOURAGING HIM PLEASE DO
NOT WASTE YOUR PRECIOUS LIFE
COMPLAINING FIND YOUR HAPPINESS
IN FULFILL YOUR ONE AND ONLY
LIFE. BISHOP AGREE REBUILD
THEIR REAL COMPASSION IS NOT
JUST BEING NICE. THOSE THEY
CARE ABOUT US WILL ALSO BE OUR
LIVING MIR'S ENCOURAGING US TO
NOT WASTE OUR ONE AND ONLY LIFE.
NO MORE AMENABLE TO WITH
KINDNESS AND GRATITUDE BEYOND
WORDS. THANK YOU REVEREND WE
ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS TO
REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN US FOR
THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE JOIN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BIGELOW. AS HE
LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE MISTER
BIGELOW THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE JOIN ME IN
SAYING OUR NATIONAL PLEDGE I
PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE. TO THE FLAG.
A AND. LITTLE SORRY. THANK YOU
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
THURSDAY FEBRUARY TWENTIETH
TWENTY TWENTY RECENTLY MET AT
NINE AM ARE- KEVIN MULLIN
SPEAKER PRO TEM OF THE ASSEMBLY
PRESIDING CHIEF CLERK SUE
PARKER AT THE DESK READING
CLERK KATHLEEN AND LOUIS
READING THE ROLES CALLED
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMBLING THE
QUORUM CALL THESE AND THIS
JUROR CALDERON MOVES. AND MR
LACKEY SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH. EXHORTATIONS
HAVE PETITIONS THERE ARE NONE.
INTRODUCTION REFERENCE TO BILLS
WILL BE DEFERRED REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES FOR
THE DAY. FOR LEGISLATIVE
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BONTA
AND EGGMAN. FOR PERSONAL
BUSINESS ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
COOLEY. CUNNINGHAM AND
OBERNOLTE. FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS FRAZIER AND WALDRON.
AND FOR MATERNITY LEAVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SABRINA
CERVANTES MISTER CALDERON YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTIONS THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO SUSPEND ASSEMBLY
RULE ONE EIGHTEEN A TO ALLOW
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS GRAYSON AND
REBEKAH BAUER CAN TO HAVE
GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS ON THE
FLOOR TODAY. THEIR GUESTS WILL
BE SEATED AT THEIR DESK.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I ALSO REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE. TO ALLOW ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
WEEKS TING AND DAVID CHIU TO
SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMORY TODAY.
AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER. MR KILEY
FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU RISE SIR
I'M MISTER SPEAKER I'D LIKE TO
MAKE A MOTION. PROCEED WITH THE
MOTION SIR. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT FOR A SUSPENSION OF THE
RULES TO WITHDRAW AB NINETEEN
TWENTY EIGHT WHICH SUSPENDS AB
FIVE FROM THE LABOR AND
EMPLOYMENT COMMITTEE AND TO
IMMEDIATELY TAKE THE BILL UP
TODY WITHOUT REFERENCE TO FILE
THIS IS A MOTION ON BEHALF OF
COUNTLESS CALIFORNIANS WHOSE
LIVES HAVE MINISTRY RALLY
YOU'VE MADE A MOTION THAT
REQUIRES A SECOND. WE HAVE A
MOTION AND A SECOND ON THE
FLOOR THIS IS A MOTION TO.
SUSPEND THE RULES AS WELL AS
SUSPEND THE CONSTITUTION. THIS
IS A TWO THIRDS VOTE THRESHOLD
MEMBERS THIS IS A PROCEDURAL
VOTE BY MR KILEY TO SUSPEND THE
RULES AND SUSPEND THE
CONSTITUTION PROCEDURAL VOTE
MEMBERS MR KILEY IN THIS CASE-ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. IN
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NOBLE CARPAL OVERALL. MR KILEY
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MEMBERS IS A PROCEDURAL VOTE
MISTER CALDERON ASKING FOR NOW.
IT'S CALLED ONCE ASKINGFOR A
NO VOTE THIS IS A- TWO THIRDS
VOTE THRESHOLD. MISTER CALDERON
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE. MS
CALL RUNS ASKING FOR NO VOTER
MISTER KILEY IS ASKING FOR AN
I. OKAY. MISTER MISTER. KILEY
MOVES A. MEMBERS THIS IS A
PROCEDURAL VOTE. THAT HAS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE THRESHOLD. MR KILEY
IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE.
MISTER CALDERON IS ASKING FOR A
NO VOTE. ON THE SUSPENSION OF
THE RULES AND SUSPENSION THE
CONSTITUTION.
CLICK ON CLOSE
ROLL EYES FIFTEEN KNOWS FIFTY.
THAT MOTION FAILS. MS MELENDEZ
FOR WHAT PURPOSE RIVES MISS
MELINDA I'M I JUST HAVE A
QUESTION MISTER SPEAKER BE
COULD PROVIDE A POINT OF
CLARIFICATION ON WHY WE HAD A
SUSPENSION OF THE CONSTITUTION
FOR THAT VOTE. IS A
PARLIAMENTARY INQUIRY BY MISS
MELENDEZ WHY THE SUSPENSION OF
THE CONSTITUTION AND TWO THIRDS
VOTE THRESHOLD. THE
CONSTITUTION REQUIRES THAT
BILLS BE READ THREE TIMES ON
THREE SEPARATE DAYS. MR KILEY
WAS- ASKING FOR SENSUALLY WHARF
TO SEND THE BILL TO THE FLOOR
AT THIS TIME AND THAT'S- NOT
APPROPRIATE UNDER THE RULES OF
CONSTITUTION SO TO DO THAT WE
HAVE TO SUSPEND THE RULES OF
THE CONSTITUTION WHICH IS A TWO
THIRDS VOTE THRESHOLD. AND THAT
IS PURSUANT TO ARTICLE FOUR
SECTION. EIGHT THE ONE. THANK
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO GAS
INTRODUCTIONS I BELIEVE MR
GRAYSON MR GRAYSON. EVERY YOUR
GUESTS ARE HERE MR KILEY WERE
MOVED ON FROM MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THIS IS. NOT
MISTER GRACE ENOUGH I CAN HAVE
YOUR PATIENCE WE'RE TRYING TO
RESOLVE AN ISSUE REGARDING
MOTION.
LATER RIGHT NEVER.
MEMBERS WHILE SOME LIVELY
DISCUSSIONS IN SIOUX IN THE
WELL OF THE ASSEMBLY WE ARE
GOING TO MOVIE GUESS
INTRODUCTIONS FOR THE MOMENT.
MR GRAYSON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR SPECIAL GUEST
INTRODUCTION THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER MY PATIENCE IS BROUGHT
ME THIS THUS FAR SO- I WOULD
LIKE TO INTRODUCE A VERY
SPECIAL GUEST THAT I HAVE- WITH
ME AN ASSOCIATE OF IN THE
GALLERY BRITAIN DATA BROUGHT
SOME LIFELONG FRIENDS. AND ALSO
ALONG WITH THEM VISITING TODAY
I HAVE MY LOVELY WIFE AND
FRIEND AND- THE LOVE OF MY
LIFE- WELL IT JUNE IT'LL BE
THIRTY TWO YEARS- WE GOT
MARRIED WHEN WE WERE FIVE. AND
SHE'S A COMPANY ME TODAY AND I
AM PROUD I AM PROUD TO BE TO
HAVE. WE CALL HER HUSBAND.
MOVING TO BUSINESS ON THE DAILY
FILE. OKAY ON RECONSIDERATION
FILE ITEMS ONE TWO AND THREE
ARE TO BE TEN YOU'D. ON SENATE
THIRD READING FILE ITEM NUMBER
FOUR PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS
WE ARE MOVING TO A VOTE ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. I WAS FIVE
THREE SEVEN AS A MEMBER MEMBER
WISH REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. SEEING AND
HEARING NONE THE CLERK WILL
READ THE SECOND A CONSENT
CALENDAR HOUSE RESOLUTION
EIGHTY TWO BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
PATTERSON RELATIVE TO
CALIFORNIA AEROSPACE AND
AVIATION DAYS CLERK WILL OPEN
THE WRONG CONSENT CALENDAR ALL
MEMBERS VOTER DESIRE TO VOTE
MEMBERS THIS IS THE CONSENT.
CALENDAR ALL MEMBERS VOTER
DESIRE TO VOTE. ALL MEMBERS
VOTE WHO DESIRE TO VOTE. CLICK
WELL CLOSER ALL TIED ABOUT ISIS
SIXTY FIVE KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
THE CLERK READ THE REMAINING
ITEMS ON CONSENT ASSEMBLY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE SIXTY
EIGHT. I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO AND
SENATE CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
EIGHTY ONE I SIXTY FIVE NO ZERO.
MOVING TO ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS
FRIDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY EIGHTH
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION MONDAY FEBRUARY MARCH.
PARDON ME MONDAY MARCH THE
SECOND. FLOOR SESSION IS AT ONE
PM.
MEMBERS OF THE ABSENCE OF
OBJECTION A QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED. AND WE WILL NOW MOVE TO
PREVIOUSLY ANNOUNCED
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY MEMBERS
WEIRD A GERMAN XIN MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CNVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. THANK YOU MEMBERS PLEASE
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING
MEMBERS WERE GRAN PRIOR
PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN
IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
TAKING FOR YOUR ADJOURNMENTS IN
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER COLLEAGUES I RISE TO
ASK OUR BODY TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF JAMES FLOOD A VERY
PROMINENT MEMBER OF OUR SAN
FRANCISCO COMMUNITY. JAMES
FLOOD ALSO KNOWN AS JIM WAS
BORN ON MAY EIGHTH NINETEEN
THIRTY NINE AT SAINT LUKE'S
HOSPITAL OF SAN FRANCISCO. A
FLOOD FAMILY HAS HELPED SHAP
SAN FRANCISCO INTO WHAT IT IS
TODAY. HIS GREAT GRANDFATHER
JAMES CLEAR FLOOD FIRST ARRIVED
TO SAN FRANCISCO IN EIGHTEEN
FORTY NINE HOPING TO STRIP.
GOLD TO HIS DISMAY HE DIDN'T
FIND MUCH GOLD BUT DURING THE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES HIS
INVESTMENTS IN SILVER MINING
EARNED HIM THE TITLE AS THE
SILVER KING. FLOOD YOU JUST CAN
TO CONSTRUCT A NUMBER OF ICONIC
BUILDINGS INCLUDING THE PACIFIC
UNION CLUB ON KNOB HILL. IN
MOST NOTABLY THE FLOOD BUILDING
ON MARKET STREET AT THE CORNER
OF MARKET EMPOWER ALL RIGHT
NEXT TO THE VERY FAMOUS CABLE
CAR TURN. JIM GREW UP EXPLORING
THE BEAUTIFUL MARBLE GRANITE
HALLS OF THE FLOOD BUILDING
PASSING BY OFFICES THAT ONCE
HOSTED. THE SOUTHERN PACIFIC
RAILROAD THE F. W. WOOLWORTH
COMPANY IN THE PINKERTON
DETECTIVE AGENCY AMONG
COUNTLESS OTHERS. JIM WENT TO
HIGH SCHOOL. AT THE CAPE SCORE
SANTA BARBARA GRADUATE FROM
STANFORD UNIVERSITY WITH A
DEGREE IN INTERNATIONAL
RELATIONS IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE. HE WORKED AS A TOP
EXECUTIVE AT WELLS FARGO FOR
TWENTY FIVE YEARS UNTIL HIS
FATHER. PASSED AWAY I WHICH
POINT HE DIRECTED HIS EFFORTS
TO MANAGING AND RESTORING. THIS
GRANT FLOOD BUILDING HIT
INHERITED FROM HIS FAMILY.
THROUGH THE NINETEEN NINETIES
HE SPENT FIFTEEN MILLION
DOLLARS RENOVATING THE BUILDING
TO ITS FORMER GLORY. TODAY THE
BUILDING HOUSES OVER THREE
HUNDRED AND FIFTY TENANTS. FROM
AROUND THE WORLD INCLUDING THE
FAT THE FLAGSHIP STORE FOR GAP.
IN RETAIL STORES FOR URBAN
OUTFITTERS. ANTHROPOLOGIE IN T.
MOBILE. THOUSANDS OF NATIVE SAN
FRANCISCANS AND TOURISTS ALIKE
ADMIRE THE BUILDING EACH AND
EVERY SINGLE DAY YES SOME OF
THE MOST AMAZING IN ORNATE
ARCHITECTURE OF ANY COMMERCIAL
PROPERTY IN SAN FRANCISCO. JIM
WAS KNOWN TO HIS FRIENDS AND
FAMILY OF THE CONSTANT VENTURE
IF HE WASN'T HORSEBACK RIDING
ON THE PENCIL HE WAS FLY
FISHING IN THE ROCKIES OR DIE
CUTTING IN MARYSVILLE OR
ENJOYING HIS SEASON TICKETS AT
STANFORD FOOTBALL GAME. JIM
PASSED AWAY THIS TUESDAY IN
JACKSON HOLE WYOMING AFTER
EXPERIENCING A HEART ATTACK. HE
WAS EIGHTY YEARS OLD. HE WAS A
VOTER HUSBAND TO HIS WIFE OF
FIFTY FOUR YEARS ASTRID SUMMER
FLOOD IN A DEVOTED ATHER TO
HIS THREE DAUGHTERS KAREN FLOOD
CRISTINA FLOOD CAME IN THE SELF
FLOOD WILSON. HIS WIFE DOLLARS
AND SEVEN GRANDCHILDREN CARRY
ON THIS FAMILY LEGACY FOR HIM.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A JOURNEY IN
THE MEMORY OF JIM FLOOD. THANK
YOU MISTER TANG AND MISTER
DAVID CHIU YOU ARE ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS IS GERMAN.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I JOIN
MY WEBSITE COLLEAGUE IN ASKING
THAT WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY
OF JAMES FLOOD A PILLAR IN OUR
SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY. JIM
ONCE REMARKED MOST PEOPLE HAVE
NEVER HEARD OF THE NAME FLOOD.
I THINK THOSE OF US WERE SAN
FRANCISCANS WOULD DISAGREE. THE
FLOOD FAMILY HAS PLAYED A VITAL
ROLE IN OUR CITY SINCE THE
EIGHTEEN SEVENTIES. NOT JUST
WITH THE ICONIC BUILDINGS THAT
THEY HELP TO BUILD ON THE TOP
OF KNOB HILL. AS WELL AS AT THE
CORNER OF POWELL AND MARKET
STREET THE FAMOUS FLOOD
BUILDING. A HISTORIC LANDMARK
THAT IS WITNESS MANY CHAPTERS
IN SAN FRANCISCO HISTORY. A
BUILDING THAT ONCE HOUSED
DASCHLE HAMMER WHO WROTE THE
MALTESE FALCON WELL WORTH THE
GAP THE NUMEROUS NONPROFITS AND
CONSULATES. IN MANY WAYS JIM
WAS A SAN FRANCISCO LANDMARK IN
HIS OWN RIGHT. A NATIVE TO OUR
CITY HE GRADUATED FROM STANFORD
BECAME A BANKING EXECUTIVE.
MANAGE THE FLOOD BUILDING WAS
INSTRUMENTAL TO HELPING TO
PRESERVE THE HISTORIC BUILDING.
HE WAS AN INCREDIBLY WARM
FRIENDLY AND GENEROUS MAN A
BOARD MEMBER OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO GENERAL HOSPITAL A
SUPPORTER OF MANY COMMUNITY
CAUSES AND AS WAS JUST STATED
HE WAS AN AVID OUTDOORSMAN AND
FOR EVER LOYAL TO OUR SAN
FRANCISCO FORTY NINERS. THE
LEGACY OF JIM FLOOD WILL LIVE
ON THROUGH HIS FAMILY THAT HAS
ALSO BEEN DEDICATED TO OUR
COMMUNITY. WE EXPRESS OUR
DEEPEST CONDOLENCES TO HIS WIFE
HIS THREE DAUGHTERS AND SEVEN
GRANDCHILDREN. AS SAID BY HIS
DAUGHTER MY FRIEND KAREN FLOOD
THE HEAD OF THE UNION SQUARE
UNITS AT THE UNION SQUARE
IMPROVEMENT DISTRICT. HIS LIFE
HAS BEEN ONE. LONG ADVENTURE.
TODAY WE WISH JIM WELL AS HE
ENTERS HIS NEXT ADVENTURE. AND
WITH THAT I ASKED WE ADJOURN
AND THE MEMORY OF JIM FLOOD.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN. MISS
WICKS YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMANS IN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER I ASK OF
THIS ASSEMBLY GERMAN MEMORY
WHITNEY DOTSON A FORMER MEMBER
OF THE EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK
DISTRICT WHO PASSED AWAY LAST
MONTH. WHEN HE WAS A LEADER IN
THE BAY AREA COMMUNITY IN ITS
EFFORTS TO BUILD A BRIDGE
BETWEEN EAST BASED CONSERVATION
AND SOCIAL MOVEMENTS WHITNEY
GREW UP IN PART CHESTER VILLAGE
WHICH WAS A COMMUNITY BUILT IN
THE NINETEEN FIFTIES. AND WAS
ONE OF THE FIRST PARTS OF
RICHMOND THAT WAS OPEN TO
AFRICAN AMERICAN HOME BUYERS.
MOBILIZING ORGANIZING IS
SOMETHING THAT WOULD
EXPERIENCEDAND LEARNED FIRST
HAND FROM HIS FAMILY. IN THE
NINETEEN SEVENTIES WHEN
DEVELOPERS THREATEN TO TURN
BURNER MARSH. INTO A AN AIRPORT
IN RICHMOND WHAT HIS FATHER
MOBILIZED IN THE COMMUNITY IN
WHICH HE LATER PICKED UP THE
FIGHT AS- THEY WERE PROPOSES TO
TURN IT INTO. AN INDUSTRIAL
PARK. HE ULTIMATELY PRESERVE
BURNER MARSH GIVING THE PUBLIC
ACCESS TO THE SHORELINE AND
CREATING A PLACE FOR THE
COMMUNITY TO WALK AND EXERCISE.
WITH HIS EDUCATION PUBLIC
HEALTH WHEN HE SAW THE
CONNECTIONS BETWEEN THE LACK OF
OPEN SPACE. AND LOW INCOME LOW
INCOME HEALTH PROBLEMS. LIKE
ASTHMA HEART DISEASE AND
DIABETES. WITH HIS WORKING
CREATING OPEN SPACE IN RICHMOND
WHITNEY ONE AND ELECTED SEAT ON
THE BOARD OF THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT FROM TWO
THOUSAND NINE AT. TWENTY
NINETEEN. HE ALSO SERVED AS A
BOARD MEMBER ON THE GOLDEN GATE
AUDUBON SOCIETY WHERE HE
WORKED. ON AN ECO EDUCATION
PROGRAM THAT SERVED THREE
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS IN NORTH
RICHMOND. THOSE WHO KNEW WHAT
HE DESCRIBED HIM AS A
PASSIONATE CONSERVATIONIST AND
A STRONG ADVOCATE OF THE BEARS
ENVIRONMENTAL AND GREATER
COMMUNITY. FOR HIS WORK IN THE
EAST BAY REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT
FOR HIS WORK THE EAST BAY
REGIONAL PARK DISTRICT RENAME
PRINTER MARSH. THE DOTSON
FAMILY MARSH. AND FIRST WORKING
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE COMMUNITY
WHITNEY WILL BE GREATLY MISSED
BY EVERYONE. I ASK THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE DURING HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU AS WELL. YOUR AGAIN
RECOGNIZE ADDITIONAL THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER. I RISE TO ASK
THE ASSEMBLY ADJOURNED THE
MEMORY OF GLENN YES SUDAH WHO
PASSED AWAY EARLIER THIS MONTH
ON FEBRUARY FOURTEENTH. GLENN
WAS KNOWN AS THE CO FOUNDER AND
CO OWNER OF THE BERKELEY BOWL
WHICH IS AN INSTITUTION FOR
HEALTHY FOODS AND PRODUCE NOT
ONLY FOR BURKE THE BERKELEY
COMMUNITY BUT FOR THE GREATER
BAY AREA. GLENN LEARN ABOUT PRO
TO FARMING AT AN EARLY AGE HIS
FAMILY WAS ORIGINALLY FROM
JAPAN AND HIS FATHER AND
GRANDFATHER SETTLED IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA WHERE THEY WERE BOTH
PRODUCE FARMERS. DURING WORLD
WAR TWO LENS FAMILY WAS
INCARCERATED IN AN INTERNMENT
CAMP IN CODY WYOMING. DESPITE
THE FAMILY'S INTERNMENT THEY
CONTINUE TO FARM DURING THAT
PERIOD. FARMING AND PRODUCE HAD
BEEN A SIGNIFICANT PART OF
GLENN'S BACKGROUND. AND HE WAS
COMMITTED TO PROVIDING A
VARIETY OF FRUITS AND
VEGETABLES TO THE BAY AREA
COMMUNITY. GLENN AND HIS WIFE
DIANE OPEN THE FIRST BERKELEY
BOWL IN NINETEEN SEVENTY SEVEN
AND A SECOND STORE IN TWO
THOUSAND NINE. KNOWN AS THE
BERKELEY BOWL WEST. BERKELEY
BERKELEY BOWL AIMS TO PROVIDE
THE BAY AREA WITH THE BEST AND
MOST FOR AIDID SUPPLY OF FRUITS
VEGETABLES. GLENN WAS TIRELESS
IN ENSURING THAT THE BAY AREA
AND THE SURROUNDING COMMUNITIES
HAVE ACCESS TO. AFFORDABLE AND
HEALTHY PRODUCE STOCKING UP ON
PRODUCE FROM FARMS. ALL OVER
THE REGION IN THE STATE. HE HAD
A COMMITMENT TO CREATING A
BUSINESS THAT SERVE THE
COMMUNITY. WITH HIS KNOWLEDGE
AND PRODUCE FOOD. THOSE WHO
KNEW AT THOSE TWO SHOPS OR WORK
TO BERKELEY BOWL. NEED GLANCE
AT AN ACTIVE PRESENCE OF
BERKELEY PAUL. HIS COMMITMENT
TO PROVIDING AFFORDABLE HEALTHY
FOOD WITH F. WAS EVIDENT IN HIS
WORK ETHIC. IN THE OVERSEAS
MARKETS TRYING TO FIND BEST PRO
FOR HIS FOUR. LETTER TO SAM
BURKE ONTO A POPULAR TO.
ANALYST READY OF HELP BUDGET
DOUBLES PRODUCE. AND WITH
PEOPLE FROM LITERALLY ALL OVER
THE WORLD MADE A POINT TO STOP
BY WHEN THEY'RE- PLAYING. LET
ME EXT. THIS CAN FOR HIS WORK
AND PROVIDING THE VERY HEALTHY
FOR. I AM VILLAGE. JR HIS
MEMORY. THANK YOU MISS WICKS.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
OF THE DESERT PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST RETURNING
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL ALL
OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE PASS
RETAIN A MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUE SEEING HERE NO FOR THE
BUSINESS SUMMARY TO ENTERTAIN A
MOTION TO ADJOURN MISTER JONES
SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE STANDS
ADJOURNED UNTIL MONDAY MARCH
SECOND. AT ONE PM WE ARE
ADJOURNED.